good
good afternoon and welcome gene shiz er
mr. Attorney General members of the
administration and faculty family
friends and fellow graduates I am
Jessica ESO kawa president of the
Student Senate it is an honor to address
you all today someone recently described
my leadership style this year as
characterized by unbridled enthusiasm so
in keeping with that I extend heartfelt
congratulations to the Columbia Law
School class of 2010 in our time here
it's been tempting to get bogged down
fixating on how much work law school can
be how many cases you have to read for
tomorrow how our law texts are awfully
heavy or how you haven't paid your
Columbia rent in a while but today we
have the wonderful opportunity to put
everything on hold during the ceremony
and think as expansively optimistically
proudly and romantically about what it
means for us to graduate today and earn
our legal degrees today some will focus
on what we will achieve it is a humbling
honor to say I have no idea what we will
accomplish but I suspect there are no
limits as president of the students on
it I had the opportunity to observe what
my classmates could achieve in law
school and I am confident that we are a
group of seven hundred something people
who engage very critically thoughtfully
and actively with whatever environments
were headed towards in both legal and
non-legal capacities during our time at
Columbia Law School one achievement in
particular is the creation of a
wonderfully vibrant community the jg
lobby isn't just where study groups meet
it's where friends can be and because of
our classmates efforts and contributions
our law school experience has been
anything but isolating
we've attended cultural events watched
epic moot court battles mingled with
distinguished guests of the law school
cheered on our Dean's cut basketball
team laughs tadao ourselves during the
Law Review show and wild away the hours
at bar reviews today we sit with the
friends who defined our law school
experiences the ones who helped us
survive finals and commiserated over the
job search as well as supported us
through moments even scarier like the
personal health scares or the loss of
loved ones and in spite of this vibrant
community our classes also exhibited the
ability to conceive more broadly of what
communities we are apart of and no
obligations to beyond the four walls of
Jerome greenhalgh to name just one
example this year we have the
opportunity to attend a barristers ball
that benefited haiti disaster relief i
was incredibly proud that we as a
community check our moment of
celebration and shared it with those
less fortunate similarly during our time
in law school we've seen people throw
themselves into pro bono projects
caravans elections and countless
advocacy issues these endeavors hint at
what can achieve together as members of
this class as well as in our individual
capacities with our legal degrees in
hand I hope will continue to be inspired
by the same passion that helped us
thrive in law school there's always a
risk of forgetting why you came to law
school and what compelled you towards
this intellectual pursuit and profession
in the first place but we came here to
empower ourselves and to enhance our
ability to pursue what we care about I
hope that it's not just days like
graduation where we reflect on our roles
and draw inspiration from ourselves and
the passion of individuals like our CLS
classmates I am confident that this will
protect us from directionless ambition
and will instead lead to a fulfilling
life in the law and a
tacular ruckus joy-filled 50th year
reunion so today we graduate from law
school slightly less fit and a little
less well rested than when we first got
here but we're also graduating with an
excellent legal education we have been
taught by some of the most brilliant and
distinguished professors and have been
guided by carrying administrators our
professors have prompted us to think in
new ways by pushing us to ask the most
critical questions about the norms and
laws that shape our society and
ourselves on behalf of our class I'd
like to sincerely thank all of them
and lastly while law students are
notorious for graduating with a
tremendous amount of debt I think the
one debt will all happily acknowledge is
the one we owe to our families today we
celebrate them I wouldn't be standing
here if it weren't for mine so thank you
to my wonderful family and to all the
families here today for making this
accomplishment possible
class of 2010 friends it's been an honor
thank you for all the wonderful times I
can't wait to see what we will all
accomplished and I wish you all the best
of luck I am now delighted to introduce
Mia white JD class of 2010 who was
elected Speaker by popular vote of the
JD class
thank you for the opportunity to speak
today I wanted to use this platform to
honor all of our accomplishments and so
I gave some thought to the inspirational
quotes that helped me over the last
three years and I thought I might share
one with you unfortunately what I came
up with what sprung to mind first was
from Winston Churchill who said when
you're going through hell keep going
that wasn't exactly the message of
inspiration that I was going for so I
went back to the drawing board and i
discovered that what I've been most
profoundly impressed by is all of you
the hardest part about law school is
that real life continues real life
doesn't stop just because we're here and
that's a lesson that will continue to
learn for the rest of our professional
lives on our very first day here as long
as one else we were red highlights of
this varied a list of accomplishments of
what we'd all done before coming here
and to be honest that was a bit much
because some of you are very
intimidating people but now on our last
day we celebrate what we've done here
and as many of you know I spent my share
of time in the drum green lobby and I
got a chance to see a lot of you in
action and I saw some of you become
performers as rock stars at stand-up
comics I screen writers and bloggers you
won national competitions some of you
fell in love some of you fell in love
with each other
some of us suffered the loss of a loved
one and some of us battled serious
illness some of you created new programs
and initiatives and volunteered hundreds
of your hundreds of your hours without
any credit or expectation there of some
of you started families and some of
those new people are here with us today
a few of you continue to work and even
ran your own businesses now this is not
to say that if you haven't done any of
these things that today's accomplishment
is any less the classes the papers the
discourse the exams these are challenges
worthy of their own merits and one thing
we all share in common is that we made
it this class yes
this class has a personality an energy
and a real voice and it's that spark
that God is here in the first place it's
that spark that will lead us to our
continued success we are in an era where
following the pack doesn't always lead
to foolproof success nor frankly does it
lead to personal fulfillment necessarily
we will have to get creative thankfully
you are some of the most impressive
creative people I have come to know and
I want to say to you today that we are
more than just the false dichotomies of
corporate or Public Interest more than
just transaction or litigation our
potential goes beyond the limits of the
job market of today and we are more than
the limitations and labels that we place
upon ourselves we are charged with the
duty about holding the values of
equality and justice regardless of our
practice area our challenge going
forward today is to stay true to who we
are and allow that to guide us in our
decisions to remember that we are
siblings sons daughters parents and
friends and partners and now we can add
lawyer to that list perhaps the second
thing we all share in common is that not
a single one of us got here alone so I'd
like to take a moment to thank all the
people who helped get us here today
every family member and friend to the
people on the other end of our phone
calls to the people who put up with our
crazy hours and unpredictable schedules
to every person here who was a roommate
god bless you
and thank you to the people who made
sure we ate a home-cooked meal every now
and then and of course because I'm up
here thanks mom congratulations to the
class of 2010
I am now delighted to introduce chins
will conquer LLM who will speak for the
master of law and doctor of science and
law class of 2010 hadn't been elected by
popular vote by those classes
fellow graduates distinguished guests
ladies and gentlemen welcome Attorney
General Holder we are honored to have
you with us today I thought long and
hard about what I should stay up here
Dean Greenberg cobran might say I spent
a little too long thinking I considered
one or two rhetorical flourishes about
how incredible our LLM year has been too
easy to trite to 20th century after much
deliberation I resolved I would talk to
you about the true meaning of reflected
glory the NLM is that rare breed of
lawyer part practitioner part academic
we come from all over the world we have
suspended successful careers some of us
bringing spouses and children along for
the ride all for one more year as a
student and all the free pizza Columbia
Law School can provide one more year of
fighting to stay awake in butler library
of dying on the inside when that
intelligent remark you wanted to make in
class didn't quite come out the way you
planned of being so exhausted from
finals that even your eyelashes hurt yes
the LLM is a rare breed but not just for
this slightly masochistic reason this
graduating class has a particular gift
the gift of timing 2009 was quite a year
the global economy was sinking
unemployment rates were skyrocketing nor
firms began joylessly shedding staff
personally I thought it was the perfect
time to quit my job relocate and start a
master's
talk about expert timing you see the
graduating class of JD's can be forgiven
they signed up to law school long before
anyone thought it was a remotely good
idea to put the words credit and crunch
together that the LLM we saw it all
coming we probably had a fair idea of
when the crisis would really hit but we
signed up anyway yes my friends we are
the brave ones the risk takers the
Daredevils of the legal universe
right but seriously what binds us as a
community of flms really is that spirit
of adventure it's that same spirit that
helped us rescue Thanksgiving dinner
from certain disaster that led us to the
unfailing joy that is the Blue Note 2
Williamsburg's fabulous miss favela not
to mention our adventures in Mexico yes
I get it what happened in mexico stays
in Mexico I won't say another word
promise what I'm saying is yes we have
worked hard and we have really earned
this degree but we this team we have
become this network this graduating
class we have brought out the best in
each other and that makes us all each
other's true reward and we get this day
to bask in the reflected glory of our
collective achievement flms this day is
a finite resource so savor it enjoy it
step back and admire it hold it up to
the light and marvel at it for today is
a finite resource a duel that represents
all your yesterday's leading up to this
point the pride in the eyes of your
friends families your professors dean
polo that tells the story of our
achievement far better than I ever could
in closing William Faulkner once wrote
about a box that when opened was full of
stars when I was still they were still
when I moved they glinted and sparkled i
hushed the jewels glint and gleam with
reflected and refracted light
congratulations class of 2010
good afternoon my name is Katherine
Kelly and today I have the distinct
honor of presenting the 2010 Willis LM
Reese prize for excellence in teaching
I'd like to begin with the words of
Albert Einstein the hardest thing in the
world to understand is the income tax
it's probably not the inspirational
quote you are expecting but with the
perennial sting of April fifteenth just
a month behind us surely some of you
sympathize with the observation yet many
in the audience like me object to such a
bleak view of the tax system we've had
the benefit of learning its contours and
complexities with remarkable clarity
we've had the privilege of an uncommon
intellectual journey we are the students
of Professor Alex fresco knock off this
year's recipient of our award for
excellence in teacher
one thing you'll not read and professor
Raskolnikov's bio is that he generally
dislikes being introduced and he prizes
brevity almost as much as he loves the
New York Yankees so since Derek Jeter
couldn't be here today I'll try to be
concise as a scholar of tax law and
policy professor Raskolnikov champions
what is typically an unpopular cause but
he is anything but typical in fact his
basic tax class is one of the most
popular courses at Columbia Law School
why professor Raskolnikov is invariably
clear as a former electro chemist really
he died sex and explains difficult ideas
with scientific precision professor
Raskolnikov is a crowd pleaser as a
former game show host yes really he
conducts his classes with showbiz
charisma indeed his Flair has earned him
such a claim that most students know him
simply as Roscoe a prestige usually
reserved for the likes of bono or
Madonna or Pele no doubt his energy and
clarity make professor Ross colonic off
an excellent teacher but we acknowledge
him today for a more important reason
his excellence is infectious
professor Raskolnikov has a distinctive
way of bringing out the best in his
students our highest efforts our deepest
understanding our finest work he
challenges us to rise too ambitious
pursuits and he empowers us to do so the
dedication and skill he brings to every
class inspire us to attain excellence of
our own today we honor an extraordinary
educator professor Raskolnikov with this
award we recognize your exceptional
talent and we celebrate the many
achievements your pedagogy will endow on
behalf of the class of 2010 it is with
profound gratitude that I present you
with the Willis LM Reese prize for
excellence in teaching congratulations
goes back Thank You Catherine thank you
very much and thank you the class of
2010 for this great honor I must say it
it feels wonderful to win this award to
be able to address you and your families
today you know this event is even being
webcast so so some people are watching
this on the internet right now most of
them are my relatives so yes it feels
wonderful addressing you today but I
must tell you that getting here often
felt anything but wonderful in fact it
may surprise you to learn that my road
to this heavy day has been marked by
disappointment rejection and failure i
can give you many examples but i only
have time for two before they cut off my
mic so the first sad story is from my
law school days and the second is from
my time in private practice I remember
my first law school class very well it
was a small group session in torts with
a brilliant professor who seemed to know
everything there was to know about the
subject and a bunch of super smart
classmates who seemed to know almost as
much as the professor and there I was
having no clue I was intimidated nervous
but determined to participate so 10 or
15 minutes into the class I raised my
hand and answered the question or I
thought I did
what followed was the most deafening
debilitating and desperate silence I've
ever experienced the professor looked at
me and scratched his head and eventually
uttered you just restated what I said at
this point I had no idea what he said
what I said and what should I say to get
out of this terrible situation that was
it I couldn't even distinguish between a
question and an answer my professor
surely thought I was an idiot my
classmates surely thought the same the
best thing I could do to save myself
from further embarrassment was to drop
out of law school right then and there
before they kicked me out for completing
companies and that was the first day of
classes ok so my law firm story isn't
much happier I was practicing for a few
years and as many mid-level associates
do i sought career advice so when i
asked my first mentor for an evaluation
he was generally very positive i'm doing
good work he said my clients like me
other lawyers like to work with me so
things are going well but but he said
you really should be doing something
else
you really should he said become a
banker now he meant it in the best
possible way but when a fifth-year
associate is being told that he should
do something else well let's just say it
doesn't sound very promising so I went
to my second he started with the same
encouraging summary and then he said the
same dreaded word but but he said you
really should think about becoming an
academic now let me tell you that did
not make me happy not only my two
mentors thought I should be doing
something else they couldn't even agree
on what that something else was my
career as a tax lawyer looked pretty
shaky at that point and i was already 38
how many other careers could I possibly
have well things worked out I didn't
drop out of law school and I'm having a
great time teaching tax here at Columbia
what's the point of telling you all of
this they may be a lesson here for and
maybe more than one so how shall I put
it this is not the best time to be
graduating from most some of you didn't
have jobs until recently and a few are
still not sure what you're going to be
doing in a month or two it's upsetting
disappointing and frustrating I know
some of you told me this in person this
is not fun take a deep breath you're
bright energetic and talented graduates
of one of the best law schools in the
country tens of thousands of lawyers and
law school graduates could only wish
they were in your shoes it may seem that
things will never improve that they you
will never find a great
job that you will never repay your loans
never this and never that but you know
this is nonsense of course you'll do
great and if now and then you need a
concrete reminder just remember that the
guy you awarded the teaching price to
almost dropped out of Law School on the
first day of classes because he was so
sure that he could not possibly succeed
there okay now most of you do have jobs
and some will even get paid for not
working how bad can that be I mean but
still still it's hard to avoid the
feeling that you guys got a bit of a raw
deal if you only graduated five years
ago law firms and government agencies
and public interest organizations would
be falling all over themselves just to
get your attention fancy dinners in
endless lunches and boat cruises and
baseball games and not to be forgotten a
great legal career would be laid out
right in front of you for the taking
instead you have to struggle and
overcome some adversity and deal with
uncertainty it's hard not to feel that
you got a big deal well maybe you did
but not nearly as much as you might
think it is true that Columbia graduates
had an easier time on the entry-level
job market a few years ago but the
thought that this guaranteed a rewarding
and trouble-free career was a pipe dream
even then some students who graduated
five years ago realized fairly quickly
that they didn't like their jobs all
that much they were unhappy unsure about
what to do and how to do it they faced
uncertainty sometimes rejection and
often difficult choices
just the stuff many of you have to deal
with now nothing is ever guaranteed
nothing is ever laid out it's just a
question of whether the reality sets in
f graduation or a few years down the
road and to remind yourselves of this
simple fact remember that a guy you
awarded the teaching price to was told
to look for different jobs by too
sympathetic mentors five years into his
legal career and the last point I
understand that many of you are not
getting what you wanted not your
preferred practice area not the firm you
hope to join another city not the city
you want it to be in your dream job is
being delayed well you have to take
what's available it feels like you're
wasting time if you forget everything I
said until now remember this you've got
plenty of time most of you will change
several jobs and change your minds about
the jobs you have on multiple occasions
you may think now you want to do
litigation and realize a year from now
that you'd be much happier doing tax you
may think now that you want to work for
the government and realize a few years
down the road that you'd rather work for
ACLU you may think now you want to do
corporate restructurings and realize in
a few years that you'd rather be a food
critic or or a masseuse or or an
academic things change it's a long
career and you have time to try things
out when I was the age of most of you I
was a metallurgist at a small automotive
plant in lansing michigan by them i have
already left two jobs and one can
and since then I've been a law student a
practicing lawyer and the professor and
I still have good 20 years to try out
some other things so take your time do
whatever job you happen to start with
well keep an open mind about
opportunities and good things will
happen you've accomplished so much
during your time here at Columbia you
will accomplish much more in years to
come congratulations best of luck and
thanks again for this wonderful award
good afternoon classmates family and
friends it is my pleasure to stand
before you today and to share this stage
with a group of people so committed to
Columbia Law School many members of the
class of 2010 have also shown their
commitment to Columbia Law School in a
year when we all face economic
uncertainty fifty-six percent that sixty
percent of lmj SDS and fifty-five
percent of JD's contributed or pledged
to the class gift from my fellow
co-chairs and I thank you all so much
for your support giving is important at
this institution a mere two thirds of
the cost of our education comes from
tuition with the bulk of the rest coming
from annual contributions from alumni
and from the endowment many of us were
also lucky enough to receive additional
financial aid as we leave this place and
begin our careers my suggestion today is
simple find something whether you earn a
million dollars or nearly nothing
whether your contribution is financial
or personal find something there are
many causes and institutions greater
than ourselves these are worthy of our
support our talent of our passion it is
a humbling realization to know that we
all owe so much to the generosity of
others it is my sincerest hope that many
of you share with me the sense that we
all owe a measure of generosity to
someone to anyone in return Dean shazar
I am delighted to introduce my friend
and co-chair Lucie County droning who
presents you with the scroll of honour
for the 2010 class gift
you sugar it is my pleasure to present
you with this year's scroll of honor on
behalf of the class of 2010 and an
appreciation of everything that Columbia
Law School has meant to us
thank you so much everyone and
congratulations class of 2010 there are
very few days in your life that you will
always remember and today is one of them
you've worked very hard for many years
to reach this milestone you've grown
professionally and personally during
your time at Columbia you forge
friendships that will last a lifetime
you now join a very special group the
graduates of Columbia Law School members
of the class of nineteen sixty will
celebrate their 50th reunion next month
I've marched with you today in order to
welcome you into our community of alumni
please join me in thanking them for
being with us
you deserve enormous credit for your
successes at Columbia but as you know
there are others in your lives who share
that credit with you your loved ones and
friends have supported you in many vital
ways today is the day to celebrate them
to let them celebrate you sometimes when
we reach the end of something we feel
relieved even happy later this month I
know I will feel that way about the last
episode of lost no matter how many times
i watch that show I simply have no idea
what's going on seriously though I doubt
that you have only positive feelings
about leaving columbia I'm sure that
you're ready even restless to move on to
other things but you will miss the
intellectual engagement that you found
here and the mentors and friends who
shared it with you you also leave us to
enter a very tight job market and to
join a wider world full of problems in
the last month alone we've had a
volcanic eruption an oil spill and even
a car bomb in times square as I'm sure
you know you don't have the luxury of
saying yes these are very difficult
challenges and I hope those responsible
for them we'll deal with them wisely
because it's your profession perhaps
more than any other that has this
responsibility as graduates of this law
school you will be called upon over the
course of your careers to deal with the
most pressing challenges of your time
sooner than you may realize others will
depend upon you to lead this may sound
daunting but you should keep in mind
that every graduating class has been in
this position and it's also worth
remembering that many of them have faced
even harder times than you I know you
might be skeptical about this claim the
challenges of the past can seem to be
easy to manage if only because they were
in fact managed but if we filter out the
glow of nostalgia and hindsight we can
see how difficult these challenges
really work for example in may of
nineteen seventy the world seemed to be
unraveling
there were demonstrations against the
trial of Black Panther Bobby Seale in
New Haven few days later President Nixon
announced in action by american troops
in cambodia in response to this
escalation of the Vietnam War there were
violent clashes at Kent State before
people were killed and to Jackson rate
in jackson state where two others died a
friend who's here from the class of
nineteen seventy celebrating his sons
graduation told me that many of his
classmates didn't come to their
graduation in order to protest these
developments let's go back another ten
years may of nineteen sixty was also an
anxious time the very beginning of the
month the soviet union shot down an
american u-2 spy plane by the way my
guess is that the band was named for the
plane but the plane was definitely not
named for the band a few days later the
Soviets launched their fourth Sputnik
satellite these two events gave a sense
that the Soviet Union had taken a lead
in missile technology and that this
missile gap was increasing the chances
of nuclear war twenty years earlier was
an even more frightening time in may of
nineteen forty days before the class of
nineteen forty graduated nazi germany
launched an invasion of France through
the low countries within days the
British Army had to be evacuated at
Dunkirk and by late June the friendship
surrendered seventy years ago yesterday
the new Prime Minister of the United
Kingdom Winston Churchill told
parliament lita that he had nothing to
offer but blood toil tears and sweat and
that their policy would be as he putted
to wage war against him a monstrous
tyranny never surpassed in the dark and
lamentable catalog of human crime with
this window on the experiences of these
other graduating classes I hope I've
persuaded you that the problems we face
today hardly unprecedented and in ways
they're considerably less ominous than
the burdens borne by other generations
but I don't want you to think my parting
message to you is it may be bad today
but at least it's not as bad
his World War two because I actually
mean to be a good deal more upbeat than
that for one thing the challenges that
you face have a very significant silver
lining even though you've had a harder
time finding jobs in many classes before
you through no fault of your own
obviously you begin the next phase of
your careers with a maturity and a sense
of purpose that ordinarily take long
much much longer to develop this is a
manifestation of the broader truth that
every challenge we surmount makes us
stronger there's a certain wisdom
steadiness that comes with enduring and
overcoming difficult times we also learn
to savor the good times all the more
when we've seen our share of hard times
this brings me to another important
point although the classes of 1940 1960
in 1970 began their careers intense
times they've since had their share of
exhilarating experiences many of which
were almost unimaginable on the day they
graduated how many members of the class
of 1940 would have guessed on their
graduation day that they would someday
send a fax or an email how many members
of the class of nineteen sixty expected
to see the dismantling of the Berlin
wall or the triumph of the civil rights
movement I hope and expect that your
future holds the same promise and
possibilities of course the future is
impossible to predict some things turn
out worse than we expect this is the
truth that every Mets fan like me
understands more serious thank you for
that more seriously though most of us
didn't predict 911 or the severity of
the recent economic crisis no doubt
there are other challenges that we
haven't anticipated at the same time
some things turn out better than we
expect do you remember the dire
predictions about y2k or about the h1n1
virus which fortunately weren't realized
the truth is uncertainty as a fact of
life
we have to learn to live with it when
possible to turn it to our advantage in
that spirit I want to repeat the wise
advice of last year's graduation speaker
ray Davis class of 1967 you cannot
control what life brings your way
governor Davis said the best you can do
is to try to control your reaction to it
as you decide how to react remember that
nothing is more important than following
your conscience and being true to your
values most inspiring people are not
just incredibly talented but also
incredibly decent this is a rare and
powerful combination which makes me
think of al Rosenthal the former dean of
the law school passed away this year
I'll believed the true excellence could
not be attained without honesty and
compassion and we should all aspire to
follow his example this means that you
need to be committed to more than just
your personal success you will live a
very full life in the coming years and
compelling competing demands will pull
you in many directions time is the most
precious resource you will have as you
choose how to spend it keep faith with
the people you love and with the dreams
that brought you here the years will go
much faster than you expect and you only
get one chance at all of this very few
people are given the opportunity that
you will have to help shape the future I
know you will make the most of this
opportunity congratulations and thank
you all
it's now my pleasure to introduce our
keynote speaker Eric Holder class of
nineteen seventy six and the Attorney
General of the United States
I'm sure you know that Attorney General
Holder has had an extraordinarily
distinguished career both in and out of
government it's a judge on the Superior
Court of the District of Columbia the
United States Attorney for the District
of Columbia his deputy attorney general
of the united states and in private
practice at Covington and Burling before
being confirmed on februari second 2009
is the 82nd Attorney General of the
United States law school was proud to
honor attorney general holder with our
medal for excellence in February 2010
before I asked him to come speak though
there's one more thing that I wanted to
tell you in 1976 when Eric Holder
graduated from Columbia Law School one
of the honorees at his graduation was US
Attorney General Edward Lee be and so as
we honor Attorney General Holder at your
graduation it occurs to me that we might
have a future Attorney General in the
class of 2010 just as we did in 1976
please join me in welcoming Attorney
General Holder thank you thank you
ok
I got it all right don't worry things
are going to be just fine uh let me ask
you class of 2010 how's it feel how's it
feel all right now here's what I'd like
you to do stand-up find the person in
the audience is responsible for all of
this or just think about the person
who's responsible for getting you this
far look at them and let's give them a
warm round of applause
Dean schetzzer distinguished faculty
proud parents family members friends and
most importantly the class of 2010 thank
you for inviting me to share in this
moment and to join you in celebrating
all of your accomplishments that have
been and most assuredly will be achieved
it's an honor and honored to be back at
Columbia Law School although it's
something of a miracle that I ever got
into this esteem school in the first
place during my undergraduate years here
in Morningside Heights I was one of many
students on this campus who felt
strongly about well nearly everything
during my time it was the 1970s during
my senior year several of us took over
one of our concerns that black students
needed a designated space on campus
together and we went to the dean's
office in that building right over there
now this be be in columbia we proceeded
to occupy that office the target of that
sit-in was Dean Henry Colan he heard us
out he led us toward common ground and
eventually to a compromise but I'm not
sure that he was very happy about shall
we say his forced captivity in the
ultimate display of puts paw however I
still asked Dean Coleman to recommend me
for admission into this law school
and lo and behold he agreed only hit
Colombia my friends that's one of the
reasons one of the many reasons why I
love this university to return today as
our nation's Attorney General to the
place where I first studied the law
where I first dreamed of both serving
the cause of justice and our country's
Department of Justice is an
extraordinary privilege I am proud to be
part of this distinguished institution
and it is a part of me and I am grateful
to be among the first to welcome such a
talented group of men and women into
colombia's law alumni faculty family
family well let's not get ahead of
myself family and today as always I'm
just very glad to be home I was born a
few stops away from here in the Bronx I
grew up in Queens I attended Stuyvesant
High School in Manhattan and then it's
here to Stuyvesant and then I spent
seven exhilarating years here at
Columbia it was across the street that i
unraveled torts and studied for what
seemed like months with professor Rees
Palsgraf versus Long Island Railroad
Company I still don't understand it it
was in the library that I discovered and
hated contracts and grew fond of all
nighters it was in the legendary
professor Telford Taylor's criminal law
class that my interest in combating
crime and my commitment to the rule of
law was inspired and it was during
school summers that I had the
opportunity to work for the
n-double-a-cp on a few of the seminal
discrimination cases of the day this law
school defined me in ways that I am
still realizing and I'm confident that
in 35 years you too will reflect and
also realize that in important in
unexpected ways this university has
influenced your work and has enriched
your life now I've lost of course the
law school has changed since I was here
there are more international students
and offerings there are a dozen or so
journals instead of just two
and what I hear about the construction
of this 200 luxury on-campus dorm rooms
is that true when we were college
students here President Obama and I were
lucky to have hot running water in the
years since I received my diploma I
suppose I've changed too according to an
American Prospect article that was
published earlier this year i and i
quote entered columbia college in the
fall of nineteen sixty-nine just in time
to grow an afro and participate in some
heated student protests unquote well
something else has changed since 1976
when I was sitting in your seats
watching as Dean inches are mentioned
then Attorney General Edward levy
receive an honorary degree since then
something more consequential than
hairstyles and protest strategies has
evolved and that something is the law
over the past three and a half decades
our legal system has transformed in ways
that while easy to overlook or to take
for granted are critically important
consider that when I first enrolled in
this university I could not vote even
though I was 18 I could however drink
it's true now of course the right to
vote is afforded to every 18 19 and 20
year old or considered that recently
when I became Attorney General last
februari there was not a single line in
nearly 225 years of the United States
Code that referred explicitly to gender
identity today the Matthew Shepard and
James burdock which the president side
into law last year does just that
finally protecting our nation's gay
lesbian bisexual and transgendered
citizens from vicious hate crimes
those are just two examples in every
field of the law progress is being
pursued and progress is being made this
is our nation's oldest and perhaps
finest tradition since America's
earliest days young dedicated lawyers
have been using their knowledge and
their training to stand up for justice
finding that their education not only
armed them with an ability to change the
law it also provided them with the power
to change the world our best example of
this may be our earliest example the
development of our Constitution that
today it's worth remembering and
mentioning that our Constitution was not
created in a vacuum it wasn't in fact
created to correct flaws in the legal
framework that had been established by
the Articles of Confederation now don't
worry I'm not here to deliver a lecture
on the law I say that you had your fair
share of those and trust me over the
past year so have I instead I'd like to
offer you just the just the opposite the
slight but significant correction to the
history that many of us grew up studying
the history of how our nation's most
important founding document our
Constitution was established 223 years
ago today May fourteenth 1787 a motion
was made in Annapolis Maryland calling
every state delegate to Philadelphia for
the Constitutional Convention that
summer as the story goes the wise old
men of the Republic gathered to draft
what would despite its imperfections
become the greatest legal document in
the history of mankind now these framers
rightly believed that the Constitution
would provide a framework to extend
their commitment to justice and
opportunity for all and as we have been
taught it was these elder statesmen who
hoped it would serve as a shining
example for all the world the only
trouble with this story is that it is
not entirely accurate through some
interesting research two great
historians Stanley Elkins and Columbia
zone Eric McKittrick have provided a
fuller picture they have revealed that
rather than being the product of
venerable old sages our Constitution was
actually actually established at the
insistence of and through the advocacy
of young people and specifically young
lawyers those who supported the
Constitution the Federalists were on
average at least a decade younger than
their opposition several leading
Federalists were under 35 and more than
a few of them were in their 20s at 44
the oldest Federalist was George
Washington and many of his
contemporaries like Columbia University
alum john j hacks their ideas about a
strong democratic central government
during their early years spent studying
the law now this history underscore is a
trend that we've seen time and time
again in every chapter of America's
story young people it seems to me are
uniquely qualified to reimagine and in
doing so to reinvigorate the law and the
world many of the great social
advancements in our nation's history
were in no small part the result of
ideas that law school graduates
envisioned and over time implemented
this is evident whether you're looking
at the eradication of slavery the birth
of the women's suffrage movement in the
passage of the 19th amendment or the
passage of the 26th amendment that
ultimately enabled young people to
participate in record numbers in the
2008 presidential election and it is
especially true when you examine the
conception and creation of our civil
rights laws several weeks ago I traveled
to Greensboro North Carolina to
celebrate the 50th anniversary of the
Woolworth lunch counter sit-ins a small
student movement that quickly grew into
a nationwide cause and over time
inspired sweeping positive national
change it motivated several columbia law
students to take part in freedom rides
across Mississippi it paved the way for
Martin Luther King's famous march on
Washington in 1963 and it helped to
spread the philosophy of nonviolent
protests that advance the civil rights
legislation of the 1960s and I'd argue
eventually led to the election of the
nation's first african-american
president as well as the appointment of
his first african-american attorney
general the exceptional commitment then
capacity of young people especially of
those willing to devote
their legal skills and training for the
struggle for equal justice and for
opportunity always has been and will
continue to be essential in moving our
nation forward Columbia Law School has a
long tradition of graduating students
unwilling to sit on the sidelines of
history or miss an opportunity to work
toward and fight for justice take bella
bella abzug class of 1947 after
graduating from Columbia Law in her 20s
but before becoming one of the world's
leading feminists she took on civil
rights cases in the south or take Judge
Robert Carter class of nineteen forty
one the master's thesis that he
developed here eventually defined the
n-double-a-cp legal strategy in
defending the right of freedom of
association under the First Amendment
and I understand one of our other famous
alums Theodore Roosevelt was in such a
rush to make an impact but after his
first year on campus he dropped out to
pursue a life of public service think
about what he might have accomplished if
like you he had stayed here and
graduated now many of you will follow in
this great tradition in fact some of you
already are brittany kerr patrick began
a new law journal that explores the
intersection of race and law
helping to chart the future of this
still burgeoning field Justin steel is
using his background in urban planning
with his legal education to help
determine the future of land use laws
and a rapidly changing housing
environment and anitra super Wong is
helping to transform immigration and
domestic violence law around the country
there there are countless more examples
in this sea of blue before me Jennifer
so colors work on human rights Sam celg
annex on health care M&F on
international reproductive rights each
of these students each of these students
and many others are harnessing the power
of law to serve as an instrument of
change now of course you can do this in
any number of ways and you will for this
is a terrifically accomplished and
diverse class one in three among you is
a minority student you represent almost
every state in more than 50 countries
15% of you have already achieved
advanced degrees not only are you
scholars you are also soldiers cancer
survivors artists rock stars religious
leaders entertainers bankers novelist
journalist and public service no
basketball players and now you are
entering an uncertain world one burdened
by economic recession but showing signs
of recovery you are taking leave of this
campus in an unprecedented age of
challenge an era of new threats and a
time of war yet you must resist the
temptation to feel as though you have
been dealt a bad hand you have not been
dealt a bad hand you have been given a
rare opportunity consider the many
examples throughout history of people
your age with exactly your training who
have improved the course of our country
and strengthened the structures and
rules that govern our society and then
consider how many of those leaders were
trained in the law quite a few I expect
no less of each of
you whether you are heading to one of
the 30 different states or to one of the
dozens of countries represented by your
post grad jobs already you have secured
impress engulfed impressive government
in public interest positions record
numbers of you are pursuing clerkships
you will soon begin fellowships at
nonprofits and NGOs that are in
desperate need of your counsel you will
provide legal services to indigent
populations and you will despite these
hard times be entering the world's top
law firms whatever your path by any
measure you are already successful but
as much as you care about your own
future success and you should before you
have worked hard for it I urge each of
you to look for ways to serve others and
to strengthen both our justice system
and our commitment to the rule of law
not only do you have the ability you
know how you now have the credibility
and you also have the responsibility a
Columbia responsibility of course you
may be told many times over the next few
years to wait you may be told that your
vision for a better system needs
ripening or worse a reality check but I
say trust your instincts believe in
yourselves follow your own course unless
of course you're one of the two
graduates who are coming to work at the
Department of Justice where you'll be
taking orders from me never question me
whether you eventually lead movements
rule from the bench return to the
classroom run for office advise clients
or defend the accused you are now ready
to define our future you are no longer
just students of the law you are now
stewards of our nation's justice system
I believe the privilege of earning a
columbia law degree brings with it an
ongoing responsibility to use your gifts
and training to improve this system and
I hope I can count on each of you to be
partners in the pursuit and
administration of justice however you
decide to serve you may choose to offer
input into how our nation is going to
combat crime protect our national
security strengthen our education system
safeguard the environment environment or
ensure that all Americans have the
opportunity to realize their dreams and
fulfill their potential but you can all
go forward from this place and from this
moment and give meaning to the ideals
that animate our laws you can also
influence these laws in ways that call
our country to aim higher to become
better and to do more for the most
vulnerable among us but before you do I
encourage you to look back to think
about the most exciting vision you've
had for improving our laws and our
society during your time here perhaps
it's something that you're working
toward right now or maybe it's something
that you've never shared well today
write it down and print it on your brain
talk about it with one of your family
members who has supported you or one of
your friends you've come to rely on so
one of the professors that you'll never
forget then keep this goal before you at
crossroads throughout your career and
your life ask yourself have I done it
yet and just as so many other columbia
law school graduates have keep asking
this question even when your hair has
turned gray even after your afro is long
gone keep asking until your answer is
yes this afternoon as we celebrate all
that you've achieved I am eager to see
where each of you will lead our nation
and our world but wherever it is know
this we are counting on you
I am counting on you your nation is
counting on you and starting now history
is counting on you good luck and
congratulations I am proud of you all
it is my honor and my distinct pleasure
to present to you the brilliant talented
and accomplished Columbia Law School
class of 2010 I day noemi obostha Philip
Lana J Robert Abraham fear a bootable
Donna Ackerman David Adams Brian Adkins
Jessica Neidhart Augustine yo V shall
agraja cork Brian Alfred JSONP a LaGrant
a douglas allen Lemuel and in jello
Christopher angel hasta Rhiannon golu
Travis Anna tyne Harriet and a cow to
girona
Colin Calvert Scott Campbell Adam
carless Eleanor car timothy john carter
Kelly cataldo adriel Cepeda dairy x Chen
Lena chen David Chang Nicholas William
to cholo Abraham ciao Jeanne chung
Jennifer Jennifer Danielle Clark Stephen
Clark Michael Clements Jennifer coffee
Danielle Cohen Justin colannino Sarah
Coleman Jennifer cook max cooper Robert
Corp on a Korea Tanisha a creep Jacob
croak Matt Crone Megan a crawly Benjamin
Cunningham Darren's RC matthew davis
Ratner Andrew Arthur dimelo Dana del
Jerr
karel de martino Thomas door Elizabeth
joisey Kwame Leslie Dugan max j Dubin
William Matthew Dukes Nicholas Dustin
Nicholas at your best ray Matthew ekman
Maxwell j Eckstein Daniel edgers Brad
Steven Ehrlichman John WI Qin Scott
Iseman shineray iza Mitchell Fagan
Hamilton Falk Jean way fum Matthew Faye
Daniel Steven Feinberg Melvin Felton
Robert friend Ferguson Laura the bigger
gb's Figueroa yeah L Fisher John
Fitzpatrick and up later
DeMuth kokum vinny appice kevin
christopher Fogle Carl C Forbes jr.
Joshua Foster Martha fulford antonio
cusco Matthew a gallant a Newport nahar
gorg Phillip Gary Catherine Geddes david
m guest Felicia and Gilbert mark
Guiliana batra Giza Trevor Gleason
Amanda ghosal jack Adam gold Karen
Goldberg Joshua Goldman hang dong ELISA
firestone Goren a Diego's David graph
Steven goo Matthew guarnieri milosz
Bukowski Helen google Harold Goulet
Andrew haber Heba Hafez John hair Daniel
Harris Gideon heart Steven Hayes
John power Healy Andy Herren Ezekiel
Hill heaven Hillier Dina hopper Andrew
hope Jacqueline who andrew wong wendy
wang William Hughes Amanda hungerford
Alex Michael hymen jessica is okawa
Daniel Jacobson laura james matthew
hodgdon jocelyne Alfonso Jimenez James
Jamerson Mary Kate's Johnson
Jessica Danielle Jones Cassandra jos
nije cali ahjumma ng anak edition bitch
anita kalra shock and yasu spec Paul
Kong Lila konov ski adam katz Shira
kaufman Lynette's this engine katherine
kelly spot kiss ennock alina hisana
alison has Kellis sabaka read poor ji
sook kim justin Kim Britney Kirkpatrick
Rachel Helen key we can Keota Larrick o
JN coo christopher joseph vertebra Devin
kothari Erica Christian jennifer kwan
tyler Ladner nicole LaMontagne richard
lange Weber
James Larson Alexander Edward Lawrence
Harry layman William Levitt carry
levitra and really Bryant Lee Jennifer
Lee Karen Lee p charlie seungjae lee soo
jin li jinlun li liang li sorry secondly
Alyssa Lang Kristen whiskey gin leo
reynel opean Lillian lorem guerra Joseph
macias Jennifer Madden Kristen Madison
nealandjune maitre Jeffrey major
Alexander marmora autumn Martin
michael cera murkiness shondor Martin
Kabir Mason Adrian Maxwell Megan McLain
Caitlin McCusker Ryan McDevitt's John
McMahon minh Caleb McNeely nicole madam
Adam may has david mal neznam meta
Margaret marrow Corey Miller Margo and
Miller William Miller Benjamin Philip
Mills Adam mints vivec Mohan Meredith
Morgan Brian Morgenstern Josh
Morgenstern blue FM e marrone fella
sarah morris Sarah moss Brendan Mulligan
Bradley Mullins
Derek Mullins mota likha na Halawa Mina
necessary M&F Daniel noumena shocked
Edward Newton Sarah Newton Seth
Niedermayer Maria nanaka Latin not Sarah
Novick betien nurse join me oh Claire
O'Sullivan Gina Yong hak suyash pollywog
raza parwani Joanne pedone Samara pen
David Pennington Carol Perry Zoe
Pershing Foley Brittany pesca tour
Lawrence David Peters Edward Symington
flat Jennifer PO khodeti napa chania
Catherine's later
stephen paul prospectus bala John B
Quigley Jessica radbourne aleem rum she
sue veeram peau de Vere Oh Katherine
Katherine Regan Karen Rebecca Reese
amanda richardson Aaron Richardson
Jennifer Robbins Lauren Kristen Roberta
Mia robertshaw Rita Rodriguez Elizabeth
Rosado Samuel Andrew Rosenbaum John
Breck Rosen killed Maya Alexandra
Rosenthal area Elliot roesner Ryan Lee
Russell Sandra root oba Samuel Sal
Gannett jose luis i'm pedro mathon Kevin
saponara Kathryn Hauser Lily skeleton
Arielle Schneier Serena Schultz make a
Shoob Mel Abigail Schwartz
Katherine pen Scully Elliot seals Abrams
semen Mira Shah Angela Francis Shannon
geval Sharma ronita sharma Abraham way
Shrien Shaw Michelle schenker sanu
shrestha samsi Schulman c'mon see joo
chiat rescigno da chi Gary silber Joshua
Simmons Bo Simmons Paul Byrd Simone
navdeep pacing johannes cryptic Angela
Aziza smedley Aaron Foley Smith Theodore
Smith Derek zone Jennifer's a color
Zachary Soto have a Spivak port burned
or
Christopher Stanley Justin piece steel
Katie Stinson Robin young Lisa kristen
marie sullivan ye soon John tira super
Hwang Julian zabala Jonathan Ptolemy nee
KO Tong stephen  teague prashanth occur
Austin Thompson Jenna Lee Tiernan Amanda
Janet Tobin Christopher Tom Marcus Sean
Perry James Trexler hong kong people
sang natasha is yours Akane sukhiya
Saltzman Sarah a Tucker rami too rainy
david tudor Meredith you'll hate fur
shop Kelly me amar Jeremy s Vogel Andre
Bonnie just school Tim full timer Curtis
Waldo Kathleen a walker Emily wall
karina Wallin's
jia wang Jonathan wang brian ward
Deborah Weiner adam weiss sarah nicole
weston me Amari white John wilt Tod
wilkinson Michael Gillis joseph d
williams samantha williams Robert
Benjamin winning Christopher block
Christina war Daniel Wolff Eric D woke
up Andrew Walston danyang Matthew Martin
yellow bitch Jung Woo you taste on you
Samuel speak Christina you Elaine un
Heidi Ewan jeans are Irish of its
anthony jacon sipping zephan josue and
david silberberg it gives me enormous
pleasure
to present to you the candidates of the
Columbia JD class of 2010
good afternoon I am honored to introduce
the candidates for the jsd doctor of the
science of law degree Luis Ernesto
chiesa Aponte Claudia giorgia feldkamp
yani sveti l and avi odd slow-mo veldt
congratulations doctors and now it is a
real pleasure for me to introduce the
candidates for the LLM Master of Laws
degrees
Zara's Anna abdulaziz othman Oshie Jan
Olympia Helen Altman Kenji amano David
James an aenean Cooper yuuichi ando
ricardo santos from cara de andrade
santos koji araki Roberto are Jerry
Leticia areas fonseca Sandra atler
Vasily aviron Yuri Alexandrovich babakov
by young cohesion aishwarya sing Bali
Charlotte a street bart for hey Eric
benavides
Jill Benedict sunny del say Yevgenia
Borowski no Andre vertullo Bernini young
bo Hanus Maria Bora Dina Marco Ricardo
poor sorry ELISA botero Dukey Caitlin
Ryan boys Anna Jane Bradley Maximilian
Yosef Brambling Emily cake burn chi hai
Tao tie chin home Rafael calatrava Pablo
Calderon cantera gianandrea kaprat Pablo
Kappas le le oh noes and marika hua
romel Cassie's
angelica casa Nera Flores Beatrice casa
la so he move Shelly kiara chela renewed
jakub heron and France was Dawn's
Charlie Chan Khong Doreen tan from Chen
Chen Liang Chen Jing Chi Chi phone Chang
eating cho jung hee Cho equal one
fennekin shot what an akuna now young
Cola Allison Claire Corkery Roxanna
marina cortina Mendoza Carson Kramer
Pablo Andreas Cremer necklace and rage
on propane donna-marie cross marina da
Silva Prado Lucas Santana stand dumbing
hot one of the most challenging ones tie
is the Gobi Maria Elena Delle Bejtlich
such Roman Eden dovin Emmanuel death
dealer
katarina per se adil Lucas des Suarez
for a Dominguez Nick dolmens and
toasters Yoakam do see in amarilla Drago
Ludo be a lease Adela Edson camilo
Alberto enciso Venegas lova Fadlallah
forming how he are a Ferrari Leonardo
fiat plaza feel go Andrea Frederica
Mendez federico flew back Erica Foucault
Paula garcy array Svetlana German tomar
Ginsburg widow joven rd Adriana Gomez
bora tika yonas drachman Braun Amy
Elizabeth really palagi Moran's
Francisco Jose Guzman Enrique
Meytal have fun ryan matthew harley if
hey fee adi Herman Beatrice Hernandez
Hill Quiroga Mariana Isabel Hernandez
Gutierrez Alfonso Sebastian Marty ray
Martinez pio vanetti yeah sushi he died
Sean seeming home Adam Michael hawk Roth
Jacob shall hallberg Masato Houma Shh
one why whoo Christine Patricia hunter
Jeffrey Steven Hurd Yoshi agha a
keen eye now move it in ball away no way
Cheney la gloria y rabbonim taka taka
ito
Maria Ivanova prashant iyengar erik
Hartman Jasper Rico Andre and Jade check
when EG still see Mary Joseph tangia
asli caribou Zulu sorry katoh Christian
Kaufman nikolas mikhail Keller yo yo Kim
Elizabeth king Katya kid ova Takashi
kobayashi Daniel pornog yelena karlova
Alexander razzak the mail drop all of
crippled
anak rupena Christina Catalina Lance
belt yawn la sock annyeong Lee Jin Young
leave Felicity married Jessica Lehane
Ingrid lighten Rafael lingua Stephanie
cheating lung Alexandra lepchenko lee
fong li jing li tian liang jia hi Joanne
shock way Lim burned Lincoln new hai Tao
sudeep mahapatra lako Manabi Marion
caustic Amanda key jose alfredo martinez
de oz yoshihiko mataki kentaro matsumoto
Jonathan mendes de Oliveira
lee Ermey shall we madoka me amudha
alvaro Zamorin Rodriguez yusuke moto
Yanagi Jessica Malaysian Kemal NAAFI
mommy Koenig I kohei nakagawa yoshiyuki
nakai aya Nakamura I Yakko Nakamura
mommy Nakamura moon Keenum joven
Norville tanley in Korean ooh
Anders lures Nilsson Ruslan nor bakov
Chisholm chidiya diva concor Sebastian
Odo's Patrick Anya me o makki airman own
go Alan vermin yak on jos Luiz or Dean
Romero cheese ooh o taki Sylvia Paloma
Esteban Pardo chechi Leah Paris teeny
Jinsu Park Seung Joon Park one Antonio
parodi Afiya Bernadette Pascal Alex
Petra chinku Maria Clara Montez pimentel
Ravi anjaani Matthias pitco it Roberto
alejandro ramirez
David route kitty Daniel Costa ravello
Kuno Rick Steiner Rosario Maria rende
granata Carla Gabriella Reyes whoop gin
rah Carlos Luis Rodriguez Ramos a gusto
Javier real ova more on tape hiroyuki
samba maria sannin suya chasteen Natasha
Pauline Schroeder kenichi sakaguchi Amy
vaping see ow Leonardo scro Francis
Hester Simmons oreck zeman nilanjana
sing Brian sites Alexia solomou Sarah so
Manson here young song Allegra so so
Yosef step uncle Michael Steiner Miriam
shreng Christina stoop jaroslav shukhman
kuroki sugita
Sarah show our tension sooo Yama swathy
sukumar Norman Suleiman son Chauhan
Shruti Suresh Nora hisa Tanaka Tang
junction duong porn to chatham torn
Maria Dolores tahirul now terashima 10
Jen chieh joya Hillary tecum your gate
sonship I'm Sophie to ferry prachi yogi
from Bashar Stefano Valente
ludivine marine von der heyden naira
vareva ha faiella tirsia purposive
vasconcelos Nikolas Vera's juliana
bottini harbors Vieira Gabriella del
Pilar Vizcaino Nicolaos Bolognese Maria
lorena Barone Monte El Rudolfo booga
picture Deborah Deborah Alice bobner one
gin 1 Leon one Winnie one Union marina
vice Federico wilensky
whoo ginger cookie llamada my you'd my
you mean yamaguchi inbound yankoo you go
yasukawa yang Minchin yosuke yoshimoto
Alma Tzadik milta such as a low palate
our son Xiu Yin sun jinsheng so vision I
will now turn you over to Dean hither
please join me in congratulating the
class of 2010
members of the Columbia Law School class
of 2010 my friends congratulations I'm
honored to be here standing with you
today for many of us we did not reach
this day alone others have stood by us
they fed us when we would have gone
hungry they guided us when we would have
been lost and they listened to us when
we otherwise would have talked to
ourselves many in facts have come here
today once again to support us it's been
said before but it's certainly worth
repeating as we conclude today's
ceremony please join me once again in
well in thanking the families friends
and mentors who have helped us become
columbia law school graduates
then thanks the ones who got us here and
now I'd like to thank the ones who got
us through Columbia is known for the
quality of its legal education but I
will remember it largely for something
else to my fellow members of the class
of 2010 thank you for filling these
three years with laughter and
camaraderie the path to this day has not
been short nor has it always been easy
but with good friends to support you
anything is possible as we go forth into
the world I hope that we all continue to
follow our passions and to meet
challenges with fervor thank you and
congratulations
graduates following the faculty
recessional please remain in your seats
for our class picture families and
friends at the conclusion of today's
ceremony please join us in lerner hall
the glass building behind you on your
left for a reception honor in the class
of 2010 we will join you after our class
picture please rise for the faculty
recessional
Oh
you